David is with us David's in Columbus
Ohio hi David how are you hi Dave thanks
for taking my call
sure what's up I was wondering what is
the best way or what your process would
be for buying a used car if you're
dealing with somebody that's had a
terrible used car experience find a
really big stupid tax on that BMW and
feels like an idiot now and doesn't want
to get screwed yeah well I mean there's
two ways you get screwed in buying a car
used or new one is you pay too much and
two is it's a piece of crap and
mechanically right that's usually the
two ways and so how do we defeat that
well one is I want you to spend some
more time researching and shopping and
that helps you learn value so you jump
on KBB you jump on trader.com
and you're looking around you look at
cars for more than ten minutes before
you buy a car you go drive two or three
different versions of that car to three
different places and you don't buy a car
cold in other words you've gathered
information in any negotiation or
purchase we tell people to that the more
expensive the purchase the more time you
should spend researching so if you're
buying a pack of gum at the counter
don't stand there 20 minutes and have a
decision problem by the gum okay it's
gum but if you're buying a car you need
to spend more time on that and research
learn about it you know jump on consumer
reports and look at what the repair
estimates and how the repair reports are
as this car got a good reputation for
repairs and that kind of thing and so
kind of learn about the car study about
it talk to two or three dealers and ask
people maybe ask a mechanic or two about
that works on that type of car what they
think about you know what do you think
about this year's you know the this
nineteen are this year 2015 Cadillac do
you what do you think about this version
of it how's how's it how's it working
are you seeing the repairs come in so
you learn that's thing one gathering
information then thing too is if you're
if you don't
you'll competent about the mechanical
side of it to where you can get a sense
that you think you're okay on the car
then ask permission to take it to your
your favorite mechanic and pay them 50
or 100 dollars to go over the car okay
and tell you what's wrong with it if you
really want to go super deep in detail
I've never done this but I've heard of
people doing it ask the person selling
the car if you can have permission to
have your mechanic doing oil change
there's a lot of information in the oil
on the condition of the engine you know
it you know is there metal shavings in
there you got a real problem you know it
is the oil burnt do we have a valve
that's got a problem developing here and
you actually I've never again I've never
done this but I've heard of people you
can actually send off the oil and have
it analyzed and tell you what's going on
with the car engine if you really want
to go like really deep into it I've
never done anything like that but I've
heard of people they're really scared
about their purchase that did that kind
of a thing I used to turn the wrench on
them back in the 70s when you could
actually still turn a wrench on them you
didn't have to reboot the car to drive
to work on it and so I'm a little more
comfortable with the mechanics side of
it myself
and so I don't I don't do some of those
steps when I'm buying a used car but if
you've been messed over then yeah you
know you ask the mechanic to check the
transmission out check the engine out
check the hoses and belts and whatever
else is going on here and you'll know
more what you're getting into takes more
time but then you don't get messed over
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]